[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est le premier rendez vous de la
semaine et nos intervenants sont pleins
d'énergie pour débattre échanger se
contredire j'espère sur les sujets que
nous avons choisi de traiter aujourd'hui
nous commençons sur la france et
l'europe après la nouvelle offensive du
président macron sur les travailleurs
détachés cette fameuse directive qui
permet à des salariés étrangers de venir
travailler en france dans des conditions
sociales plus intéressante en tout cas
plus intéressante pour ceux qui les font
travailler
nous nous intéresserons à nouveau au
feuilleton des républicains de la droit
dé constructif est ce qu'on les virait
ce qu'on les vire pas et puis on a aussi
qui veulent virer les gens de sens
commun bref le le traumatisme droitier
continue et nous en parlerons nous
parlerons aussi de la suite des
révélations successives concernant
maintenant les hommes politiques dans
les affaires de harcèlement sexuel
un député de moselle le hareng est mise
en cause par une ancienne collaboratrice
mais il nie tout ça n'est pas très clair
tout ça de même que n'est pas très clair
le comportement de neymar le célèbre
neymar le joueur du paris saint germain
je vous en parlerai pas beaucoup parce
que c'est pas ma spécialité mais
heureusement il ya des gens compétents
autour de cette table et les ces gens
compétents je vais vous les présenter
tout de suite bonsoir daniel bilalian
vous êtes le plus compétent des
compétences puisque vous avez été le
patron des sports de france télévisions
vous êtes journaliste vous est aussi
l'auteur des évadés nous ils ouvrent âge
que publié en 2016 et où nous allons
voir bientôt la couverture apparaître à
l'écran
la voici bonsoir frédéric dabi vous
aussi vous êtes très compétent et dans
plein de domaines notamment la politique
puisque vous êtes politologue et
directeur général adjoint de l'institut
de sondage ifop
bonsoir à yves thréard
guillaume roquette à la voix absolument
inévitable il thréard directeur adjoint
à l'action du figaro éditorialistes bien
sûr pour d'autres quotidien préféré et
alexandre ii vecchio bonsoir défendre
vous êtes journaliste rubrique débats
opinion du figaro vous êtes en charge du
figaro vox l'espace de deux débats et de
controverses parfois du figaro.fr et du
figaro magazine votre ouvrage les
nouveaux enfants du siècle est paru lui
aussi l'année dernière aux éditions du
cerf alors on commence tout de suite en
entrant dans le vif du sujet avec
l'offensive présidentiel sur les
travailleurs détachés
vous savez ces salariés venus d'autres
pays d'europe et qui viennent travailler
en france en étant payé la même chose
mais avec des charges sociales qui
règlent dans leur propre pays et qui
sont ils donc sont souvent inférieures
emmanuel marc on voudrait modifier
profondément cette directive voir la
faire annuler est ce une bonne idée
eh bien oui en tout cas c'est l'avis de
jean-claude mailly le patron de force
ouvrière c'était ce matin dans
territoire d'infos chez nos confrères de
public sénat
la france a une position plutôt en avant
sur sur ces questions là j'espère qu'il
finira par y avoir une majorité
qualifiée pour qu'on révise cette
directive et notamment tous les abus qui
existe actuellement dans différents sur
les étrangers doivent payer les mêmes
cotisations quand il vivait à travail
égal salaire égal c'est ça la règle donc
il faut que ce soit appliquée partout
alors salaire égal pour être plus précis
charges sociales égales en l'occurrence
actions de vector
on vous a parfois entendu un peu
critique sur la construction européenne
mais là pour le coup voilà l'europe
sociale qui est en marche c'est une
bonne nouvelle
n'allons pas trop
n'allons pas trop vite parce que
emmanuel macron est un petit peu isolé
pour le cours sur ce dossier je pense
que ça va être très compliqué pour lui
d'obtenir d'obtenir des choses même si
je crois que ça va dans le bon sens
juste quelques chiffres parce que
souvent on dit que c'est une affaire
anecdotique et symbolique 2 millions de
travailleurs détachés en europe près de
300 milles en france dont 100 milles
dans le bâtiment donc sur le plan de
l'emploi ça représente quand même
quelque chose et puis c'est à la fois
quelque chose de concret je crois est à
la fois symboliquement c'est très fort
puisque ça s'ajoute au problème des
délocalisations et du dumping social
donc ça donne la vision d'une europe
économique non pas de la concurrence
libre et non faussée mais de la
concurrence déloyale alors moi je on va
pas juger macron tout de suite peut-être
qu'il va obtenir des choses mais je fais
le pari que malheureusement à 27 ce sera
très difficile
et moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya
deux solutions soit on démantèle les
traités mais ça nous entraîne dans
quelque chose d'extrêmement compliqué
soit on fait les choses de manière
unilatérale je pense qu' à aucun chef
d'état pour l'instant qui a le courage
de le faire mais je crois que s'il faut
on veut faire évoluer l'europe où il
faut la faire évoluer par crise et que
les manuels macro s'il veut vraiment
obtenir quelque chose doit taper du
poing sur la table et expliqué que
travaillant à détacher sont illégaux en
france tout simplement
et pourquoi ce qui le serait forcément
il très agréable après oui parce que
quand on achète des produits
l'europe c'est la libre circulation des
marchandises et des personnes
vous achetez une cravate fabriqués au
portugal
bon au portugal aussi à moins de charges
sociales et donc la cravate est moins
cher ça s'appelle l'europe et pourquoi
est-ce que ça marcherait pour les
marchandises et pas pour les gens et
bien parce que les gens eux ils
travaillent sur place c'est pas pareil
si vous voulez une marchandise ou de
l'acheter au portugal
c'est moins cher c'est normal c'est la
loi du marché mais là où c'est pas
normal c'est parce que les règles du jeu
ne sont pas les mêmes dans tous les pays
pour justement et bien faire travailler
les gens vous allez en grèce en grèce
d'abord vous payez même pas de charge
puisque vous payez tout au noir donc
c'est réglé comme ça donc alexandre a
raison il a raison s'occuper de ceux de
prendre ce problème à bras le corps
parce que ça c'est ça qu'on l'a pas
d'élection des symboliques dans macron
parce que il montre au moins qu'il a une
volonté de réformer l'europe et c'est un
symbole fort le travail des tâches et
lorsque le travail est détaché et très
impopulaires comme on le sait donc ça
n'a rien à voir votre histoire de
cravate
moi si j'ai envie de m'acheter une
cravate pas cher je peux très bien lieu
au portugal
certes mais c'est une première même pas
besoin ici
j'ai des cousins en france elle sera
taxée de toute manière mais si elle sera
taxée leur accorder certaines taxes qui
seront ils lui seront imputés donc c'est
pas tout à fait pareil que le
travailleurs détachés dit lui est bien à
des charges sociales ces charges
sociales ne sont pas payés dans le pays
d'accueil
elles sont payées dans le pays d'origine
une fois que je suis le seul vrai
libéral non merci on connaît des
journalistes détachées pour vous
remplacer votre pour on arrive à
seulement pas un sujet aussi peu payé
que moi si vous aviez fait avec davy
c'est vrai ce que dit yves thréard c'est
c'est très impopulaire 7,7 complète en
direct ces travailleurs est complètement
c'est un enjeu important pour emmanuel
macron qui a été élu par la france du
oui dans un contexte où la france du non
est très largement fait majeur et
l'alliance du oui au référendum s'il est
complet plutôt référendum du 29 mai 2005
il a eu face à lui que des candidats
eurosceptique il a besoin je pense
d'obtenir des résultats de manière plus
importante que le françois hollande de
2012 qu'elle ait promis de renégocier le
traité européen avec le résultat que
l'on sait les français sont extrêmement
je dirais dans leurs critiques qu'ils
font de l'union européenne sont très
marquée par la question des travailleurs
détachés
il ya une il ya une question que l'ifop
pose depuis une vingtaine d'années qui
êtes vous d'accord ou pas avec la phrase
suivante avec tous les traités européens
que la france a signé les gouvernements
n'ont plus de marge de manoeuvre
c'est systématiquement trois quarts de
wii avec pas la moindre différence entre
la gauche et la droite
une nuance entre les français du oui et
ceux du nom qu'il a vraiment besoin
d'obtenir des résultats pour essayer de
dans un contexte où les français sont
aussi un peu moins sévère sur l'union
européenne ils ont un regard peut être
un peu différent sur l'europe dans la
mesure où on en avait déjà parlé ici le
sentiment que la france a la solution
des problèmes est de moins en moins
prégnante dans l'opinion des français
est au contraire ce n'est question
migratoire sur la question des réfugiés
sur les questions de la sécurité
les français prennent de plus en plus
conscience que là la solution se trouve
peut-être au niveau de l'europe mais
comme le disait il
quand vous disiez vous alexandre il y a
quand même
le résultat n'est pas du tout assurée
vous disiez pas différence sur la gauche
de la droite
et d'ailleurs ils gagnent eux hugo
gagneux pardon nous dit très justement
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on a blâmé
wauquiez quand il a fait la clause
molière c'est la clause mots liés à ces
chantiers francs voire d'avoir des
traducteurs sur les chantiers absolument
ce qui est une façon en fait empêché des
travailleurs venus d'europe de l'est ont
gravé sur les chantiers soyons clairs
alors qu'aujourd'hui macron semble
s'intéresser au travail des tâches
effectivement c'était la même démarche
l'année 2000 année oui alors la première
chose déjà n'achetez pas vos cravates au
portugal pourquoi le fils de tailleur
que je servais égale une cravate savate
ça s'achète à l'ombre dont jermyn street
principe jamais essayé d'être aussi
élégant parce que c'est super c'est le
principe de base est bon il fasse cette
réflexion politique fait non je pense
que même macron joue gros parce que il
est quand même considéré comme un
européiste comme on dit et comme on dit
tous les jours aussi que le bric site
c'est une des raisons du mexique c'est
le plombier polonais je pense que il
joue gros
parce que par rapport à l'eau front
national qui est aujourd'hui au plus bas
le fait de ne pas gagner cette bataille
des emplois des tâches et ça peut lui
coûter cher quand même ça peut prouver
une nouvelle fois et nombre de français
sont de cet avis que leur offre
finalement
eh bien elle ne se gouverne pas tels que
la france voudrait qu'elle soit gouverné
et que après tout pourquoi continuer à
respecter les accords de schengen etc
il joue très gros sur le côté europe est
ce parce qu'il a quand même fait toute
sa campagne sur je suis européen etc
et s'il n'arrive pas à faire passer ces
petites mesures parce que vous avez dit
parce que votre petite mesure cette
mesure qui est lourde et c'est là où il
faut d'ailleurs pardon daniel de la
symbolique - il a livré les forces il
faudrait polonais nombre
il annonça il a raison c'est d'ailleurs
on le voit aujourd'hui avec cette
poussée de fièvre nationaliste voire
indépendantistes qui passe au alors
évidemment faut pas tout mélanger mais
il ya quand même dans ces réactions la
une
rejet de l'autre donc il faut faire très
attention et c'est pour ça qu'il a
raison mais de s'attaquer le à ce sujet
le problème le problème il sait que les
français ont toujours l'impression que
les européens les députés européens les
fonctionnaires européens s'intéresse
beaucoup plus à la taille de nos
fromages et à l'appellation de nos vins
la longueur des cracks et à la longueur
des cravates qu'aux problèmes comme
l'immigration
cette europe à vingt-sept n'a pas réussi
à mettre sur pied un plan pour limiter
l'émigration de manière cohérente c'est
quand même ça qui nous intéresse
moi je me fous pas mal que les
fonctionnaires européens s'occupent de
le désosser
bien sûr il ya un autre problème qui est
pointée avec ce sujet c'est l'adoption
les majorités qui se constitue est-ce
que sur le sujet des travailleurs
détachés
on est obligé d'avoir l'unanimité cdd d
autant que le maroc et des pays de l'est
les espagnols parions pour ce qui
concerne les chauffeurs routiers ne sont
pas actuellement en train d'être
d'accord avec emmanuel macron ils sont
contre les portugais et les espagnols
alors alexandre avait que vous êtes pour
la majorité qualifiée pour que les
nations
j'ai donné ma position à mon avis le
seul moyen de faire évoluer le rock vers
une europe de la coopération et des
états nations c'est de déclarer
unilatéralement que les travailleurs
détachés sont illégaux à mon avis et
s'en sentira pas autrement
cela dit s'il est vraiment très très
fort et si vous me faire mentir il a
peut-être un coup à jouer pour faire
peut-être même une pierre deux coups
puisque les pays de l'est qui sont
favorables aux travailleurs détachés
sont défavorables aux quotas de migros
et pourrait donc y aurait peut-être un
donnant-donnant à faire là-dessus qui à
mon avis satisferait les français dans
leur ensemble
avant il n'y a pas que sur les
travailleurs détachés que la france
entend
ramener l'europe à son point de vue il
ya d'autres sujets il était abordé ce
matin par nicolas hulot le ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire
ce matin sur rtl où il a notamment parlé
des glyphosate vous savez ce fameux
agent qui permet de tuer les petites
bêtes et les mauvaises herbes présent
notamment dans le round up et qui
semble-t-il est extrêmement dangereux
écoutez ce qu'en dit nicolas hulot est
le roi hydrocarbures
mes camarades comme vous dites qu'est ce
qu'ils ont dit a été votée il ya une
dizaine de jours
l'agneau passer au sénat elle reviendra
à l'assemblée m'enfin très sincèrement
on est le premier pays industriels qui
prenons ce type de décision sur le sur
le glyphosate désolé de vous dire si je
n'avais pas mis sur le cétacé est pas
mis ces sujets là sur la table bien ce
sujet là il serait sous le radar là
aussi flight dhabi sur le glyphosate sur
le la préoccupation écologique l'est les
français sont à peu près unanime
enfin sauf les agriculteurs attention si
vous nous empêcher de mettre des
produits comme ceux là on sera plus
assez compétitifs parce qu'on aura moins
de rendement c'est un problème classique
sac d'une manière générale dans le
contexte de crise économique et de
focalisation fera question terroriste
est question environnementale passe
largement après sauf quand les français
ont le sentiment qu'elles ont un impact
sur la santé et sur le glyphosate gpad
enquête en tête mais j'anticipe plutôt
une opinion favorable à son interdiction
qui se retrouvent en contraction en
contradiction avec les agriculteurs
maintenant nicolas hulot il est un peu
dans le même temps de même il ya le même
enjeu qu emmanuel macron c'est à dire
faire imposer son point de vue
exister dans un contexte où les français
sont plutôt sceptiques sur la réalité de
son action et sa capacité à faire bouger
les choses il y avait une enquête ifop
dans le jdd
la semaine dernière où on voyait très
bien qu'une majorité très nette de
français y compris des sympathisants
d'abus en marche vous voyez nicolas
hulot plus comme une caution
et comme un symbole que comme quelqu'un
qui aurait la capacité de faire
progresser les questions
environnementales
on en a parlé ici je crois que ce qui
est sûr si vous voulez c'est que nicolas
hulot se banalise en étant dans un
gouvernement
lui il a une fille c'est une figure de
l'écologiste une confiance de l'écologie
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec lui mais
il
venu ça et à partir du moment où il
participe à un gouvernement qui doit
prendre des décisions qui sont lourdes
comme l'interdiction du glyphosate alors
qu'on sait que le glyphosate sert
considérablement à beaucoup
d'agriculteurs et qu'il faut une période
de transition
eh bien ils perdent nécessairement un
peu de sa force de frappe c'est
exactement la même chose sur le
nucléaire on sait que c'est un un
militant anti-nucléaire vu l'eau mais il
va être actives elles sont obligées il a
été obligé d'aller beaucoup plus
lentement que son discours ne veut bien
dire donc d'une certaine façon la
position de nicolas hulot c'est c'est de
dire maintenant il faut que je passe à
l'acte donc il fallait que je rentre
dans un gouvernement
après avoir refusé à plus à maintes
reprise de vouloir participer à une
aventure gouvernementale
là il change de casquette complètement
il est devenu un homme politique est
l'homme politique est bien n'est plus
une conscience comme il l'est par le com
mais il est comme il est
or des affaires je dirais je passe la
parole à david alan juste une phrase
pour rappeler que l'europe dit le
glyphosate une période de transition de
dix ans alors que hulot dit non moins de
cinq ans et idéalement trois ans avant
de l'interdire complètement
oui nicolas hulot il a quand même
beaucoup molli depuis qu'il est au
gouvernement il a été il a été pris au
gouvernement c'est c'est un people koi
c'était un peu non il est venu comme un
people il est vu comme quelqu'un qui a
une vraie compétence la 2e rue est pour
moi il est venu avec des français face à
des rachats d'eau tous les gens qui sont
beaucoup passer à la télévision ne sont
pas seulement déplorer mais lui il est
un people il vient d'une émission de
l'aïe était il passé au dessus des
montagnes vous partir je partirai un
contrôle personnes pour moi c'est un
people il a été engagé pour ça non il a
beaucoup molly et c'est ça qui est sans
doute par rapport à ces assez aux gens
qu'il apprécie
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'ils sont
déçus c'était maintenant effectivement
il est dans le langage politique
pas tout de suite dans deux ans dans
trois ans et moi ce que j'imagine
surtout derrière ça c'est le lobbying de
sociétés comme mosanto etc etc
on sentait le fabricant du roundup c'est
qu'ils adorent ça doit être terrifiant
ça doit être terrifiant parce que ces
gens là ont à leur mercie pas mal de
gens aient effectivement par ailleurs
les agriculteurs ont raison aussi parce
que si nous nous faisons de
l'agriculture bio et sans s'en produit
comme cela dans un monde qui n'a plus de
frontières les autres vont continuer à
faire leurs produits regarder le
scandale actuellement des produits bio
qui sont bidons et qui nous arrive de
d'extrême orient ou d'ailleurs donc
comment aujourd'hui à partir du moment
où nous sommes dans un monde googleliser
et et gaffe a teasé on ne peut plus dé
prendre une décision comme celle ci
enfants sinon vous mettez les
agriculteurs au chômage alors le débat
d'ailleurs continue sur sur lefigaro.fr
il ya yves aguila qui nous dit lorsqu'il
ya péril en la demeure
il est normal que la france fasse plier
l'europe si vous étiez agriculteurs que
vous pensiez au suicide que
penseriez-vous alors en l'occurrence les
agriculteurs là ils sont en tout cas
pense avoir montré plutôt pro européen
parce qu'ils veulent pas qu'on arrête
tout de suite le glyphosate et hugo
gagne qui répond ce qui énerve les
français c'est qu'on a fait de
l'écologie politique par exemple le
diesel valoriser depuis 30 ans est
maintenant décriée les politiques de
gauche ont tué l'écologie citoyenne et
ben voilà c'est un point de vue mais
c'est aussi dans des missions tant que
ça tombe bien je vous propose qu'on
parle maintenant des républicains avec
ce feuilleton qui n'en finit pas sur les
constructif vous savez ceux qui ont peur
macron les yeux de chimène est-ce qu'il
faut les virer oui non on fait des
réunions on se revoit on temporise on
décide ça devrait avancer cette semaine
que des quinze jours voilà je vis depuis
que les 10 à 15 jours dit frédéric dabi
qui me plante mon sujet c'est pas non
parce que depuis il ya eu des prises de
positions nouvelles par exemple celle de
nadine morano qui comme d'habitude ne
fait pas dans la périphrase ces noms de
code pour traite excusez moi mais moi je
le conçois comme ça alors constructif
c'est le nom de code pour trait comme
pour traite voilà qu'elle mérite de la
clarté
yves thréard c'est aussi votre avis
écoute je sais pas si c'est mon avis
simplement que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse personne n'a pas cassé
sincèrement sincèrement le sujet à quel
est le sujet beaucoup de français se
disent mais attendez ils sont pas
d'accord ils sont plus d'accord avec les
républicains mais pourquoi ils sont pas
partis de leur propre chef
dès le début et pourquoi ils sont pas
partis de leur propre chef dès le début
parce que justement il
ennuyée leur ancien parti parce que ils
veulent les pousser à prononcer
l'exclusion et chacun sait que
l'exclusion c'est peut-être très
impopulaire en tous les cas dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de beaucoup de
français
sincèrement ce que veulent les électeurs
et notamment les électeurs de droite
c'est que les choses soient claires je
pense que pour une majorité d'entre eux
ils sont pour que les constructif
quittent le navire de la rue de
vaugirard et que et bien les
républicains se reconstruise évidemment
sans les constructif qui ne seront rien
d'ailleurs or les républicains puisque
de toute manière macron n'a pas besoin
de dons qu'ils peuvent très bien créer
leur parti
ça ne gênera à mon avis personne avec
102 vecchio environ vire pas non mais ça
paraît tellement être face et c'est un
peu un gag a effectivement qui revient
chaque running gag je pensais qu'ils
essayent de flux depuis longtemps et en
fait et en fait non c'est quand même
surprenant cette difficulté à exclure
des gens qui se sont en fait exclu de
même on se souvient que même laurent
wauquiez qui a la réputation second
journal aide à certains journalistes
d'être un ultraconservateur un dur qu'en
sens commun parle simplement de discuter
avec des individualités du du front
national ou qui ont appartenu au front
national il dit il ya une ligne rouge
intangible ils seront immédiatement
expulsée et pour des gens qui
effectivement joue dans le camp adverse
il ya beaucoup plus de difficultés donc
ça dit quelque chose finalement sur le
positionnement de cette droite là on
nous dit dans les médias que c'est une
droite ultra conservatrice proche du
front national en réalité non son centre
de gravité reste libéral européen tout à
fait modéré alors au cas où vous vous
inquiète riez à l'essor de vie que de
voir les gens me sens comme un être
exclues des républicains puisque leur
président a donné le sentiment de tendre
la main à marion maréchal-le pen y en a
un qui est contre et qui au contraire
veut qu'on qu'on les garde dans la
maison c'est eric ciotti le député des
alpes-maritimes c'était hier sur bfm tv
qu en sommellerie française
le chrétien auquel je respecte aussi ce
message refusons les anathèmes refusons
mise à l'écart les militants de sens
commun ont des convictions il croit une
certaine idée de la famille qui ne
méritent pas aujourd'hui ces insultes
permanent qu'ils ont toute leur place
aux sons des gens de conviction
ils ont leur place au sein de des
républicains ont fait des habitudes fait
absolument surréaliste on veut virer
tout le monde la gauche la droite le
parti serait se renforce en s'épurant
vous connaissez la phrase stalinienne du
point de vue il ya une ya une double il
ya une double en fait la différence
l'indifférence parce que la scène
parlementaire n'est pas une scène
visible le terme constructif est
extrêmement peu connu il a peut pénétrer
le corps social
et puis ça que ça dé constructif très
très peu et puis la vie des
organisations partisanes intéresse peut
maintenant pour rebondir sur ce qu a dit
nadine morano le peuple de droite ne
voit pas pour le maire edouard philippe
dé constructif comme des traîtres
on voit très bien qu'à une part très
importante des électeurs de droite qui
sont sensibles et qui soutiennent la
politique de transformation du
gouvernement actuel vous avez vu notre
sondage de diers sur la présidentielle
six mois après c'était un exercice de
style
mais le fait majeur c'est que 36 % des
électeurs de nicolas sarkozy de windows
qui étaient des électeurs de droite bien
de droite
ce retrait plutôt voterait en faveur d'
emmanuel macron c'est là le problème
dans lequel se trouve la droite elle
aurait peut-être dû les
elle est retranchée très vite au coeur
de l'été et les français seraient
seraient passés à autre chose
extrêmement vite
et là ça sent une sorte de poison lent
qui les gêne sans pour autant avant des
conséquences majeures dans le rapport
aux français ce qui peut conforter les
constructif c'est justement ce sondage
en se disant aujourd'hui puisque macron
serait il y avait eu 28 % au lieu de 2
24 si on refaisait les six ont refusé
l'élection ça doit les mettre les
encourager à continuer à se marginaliser
du parti du bas uélé constructifs ils
exigeraient partir emmanuel macron façon
un parti qui s'appelle les constructif
ça n'a pas de sens constructif c'est
dans le bâtiment sont détachés laissons
jamais un parti mais c'est un parti qui
de toutes manières n'aura qu'une
visibilité très faible parce qu'il
n'existe effectivement que par la
république ans après ce qu'on a vu ce
week end avec juppé recelant edouard
philippe gilles boyer on a l'impression
que les juppéiste vont devenir des
macros dhien rattaché edouard philippe
dorthe premier ministre ancien
collaborateur d'alain juppé gp a trouvé
que c'était fantastique leurs aventures
et ses loyers ancien directeur de
campagne de pub d'alain juppé je trouve
aujourd'hui conseiller spécial du
premier ministre la travailleurs
détachés aussi peut-être mais hadji nous
a rejoint bonsoir du figaro.fr alors
qu'est ce qu'on dit sur les réseaux
sociaux de sept de ces guérillas un
terme
elle a demandé sur twitter mais aussi
sur figaro.fr s'il est constructif et
est un atout pour macro sur twitter
c'est très serré on à 51% nos
internautes sur 500 votants qui sont
contre enfin qui sait qui disent non à
cette réponse même chose sur lefigaro.fr
53% pour 1800 votants à peu près parmi
les tweets les plus populaires
aujourd'hui on a notamment ce matin le
député eric ciotti dont on parlait tout
à l'heure qui disait que le feuilleton
dé constructif n'a que trop duré on ne
peut pas être dedans et en dehors de
notre famille politique
ce à quoi michael pilates et conseiller
élu à l'assemblée des français de
l'étranger et déléguer les républicains
au canada lui a répondu eric ciotti veut
l'exclusion dé constructif
pourtant quand il était au groupe
rassemblement ump à l'assemblée il n'a
pas été exclu pour les internautes qui
ne se souviennent plus
c'était un groupe parlementaire qui n'a
vécu que quelques mois à fin 2012
à l'initiative de françois fillon qui
contestaient les résultats du congrès de
l'ump qui donnait jean françois copé
vainqueur et par les internautes du
figaro la plupart de ceux qui commentent
sont de toute évidence pour leur
élection
on atterrit blossom qui est probablement
une fan de la série riverdale sur
netflix qui revient sur ce qu'avait dit
florence portelli la candidate à la
présidence des républicains qui
demandait aux constructif de partir et
de rembourser les 6000 euros perçus pour
être allé aux législatives elle écrit en
fait la raison elle est peut-être là ils
ne veulent pas partir parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas rembourser
on a anonyme 238 qui nous dit les
constructifs ont privilégié leurs
intérêts personnels à leur fidélité
partisane on ne peut revendiquer le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
peut-être la confiture les républicains
seraient bien avisés d'acter leur
défection nous électeurs attendons un
peu de clarté et de courage
et enfin on à nikaïa 10 une abonnée du
figaro.fr qui nous dit la droite doit
être clair avec un programme qui n'est
pas celui d'en marche il faudrait
assainir pour être crédible et enfin je
voulais terminer par ce tweet de raphaël
enthoven philosophe sur arte et europe 1
qui nous dit insoumis république
républicain constructive patriote
pourquoi les partis politiques sont ils
désormais des noms pluriel merci
beaucoup
non mais les mots ont leur importance en
termes sémantique veut dire pourquoi est
ce qu'on parle d'exclusion alors qu'il
suffisait que le groupe républicain
d'une bombe
vous êtes parti vous avez quitté le
parti vous avez démissionné voilà pour
nous c'est une démission ce qu'ils
disent banon on n'a pas démissionné
oui mais moi je suis je suis patron du
groupe revue cage des missions de police
où ils sont partis donc voilà pour nous
ils sont partis ce serait moins
importante mais aujourd'hui le mot
exclusion ccss payer leurs cotisations
aussi daniel alexandre avec you il est
temps qu'il ya un patron dans ce parti
pour en finir avec cette ambiance de
cour de récréation je dirais un patron
oui mais mais mais quel patron ou faut
voir quelle est sa ligne qui allaient à
quel est son projet est-ce qu'il est
cohérent surtout et effectivement ils
sont que laurent wauquiez soit le favori
qu'il est on le dit qu'il cherche plutôt
à aller chercher
effectivement les électeurs soit qu'ils
n'ont pas voté soit qui ont voté front
national les classes populaires qui
n'ont pas voté
macron puisqu'il n'a pas tellement le
choix puisque le l'espace du centre
droit est occupée par macro mais pour
convaincre juste
comment ses électeurs je crois qu'il
faut animer un minimum de clarté ils ont
trop l'habitude que la droite gagne les
élections grâce aux conservateurs grâce
aux eurosceptiques grâce aux eaux aux
souverainistes pour ensuite faire la
politique finalement de d'emmanuel
macron donc il va falloir que le patron
soit convaincant et et prouve sa
sincérité je crois que aujourd'hui à ces
électeurs là on leur fera pas de chèque
en blanc étaient bien comment vous
disiez que le lait français savait pas
très bien ce que c'était que les
constructif et sens comment ils savent
ce que c'est vous c'est la même chose ça
leur dit pas grand chose je n'ai jamais
sonder le lançon défense est là dessus
j'imagine que oui ce n'est pas non plus
quelque chose qui est très signifiants
pour une part importante de français
pour des alors ça un rôle plus important
pour les adhérents j'ai fait quelques
réunion d'adhérents l air de candidats à
l'air pendant les élections législatives
à leur demande comme je le fais pour
d'autres partir la politique j'ai très
bien vu les tensions extrêmement fortes
dans quelques circonscriptions entre
adhérents et l'air je dirais canal
historique sarkozyste voir juppéiste et
les personnes se déclarant proches de
sens commun c'était vraiment je dirais
parfois deux mondes irréconciliables
parce que d'un côté et c'est ce qu'on
voit maintenant du côté du regard des
sympathisants de droite il y avait
pendant cette campagne présidentielle
une attraction non négligeable pour
emmanuel macron ce qui est intéressant
avec sens commun c'est que c'est un peu
une construction quand même médiatique
sens commun c'est quoi c'est 7 8 9 % des
adhérents des républicains c'est
vraiment une poignée et je pense que la
médiatisation de la campagne la campagne
de françois fillon où ils ont joué quand
même un rôle assez important pour
remobiliser un peu les troupes quand il
ya eu la crise la plus
là au moment de la crise la plus forte
mais depuis il ya un petit jeu dans les
médias qui consiste à mettre sens commun
toujours en avant d'agiter l'épouvantail
sens commun justement pour renforcer le
caractère entre guillemets tirer
actionnaires de de la droite et des
républicains il faut quand même calmé
ses esprits l'un et s'employer à dire à
pas mal de journalistes qui sont peu
informés que sens commun c'est une
minorité l'intérieur des républicains et
que la plupart des républicains qui sont
attachés à ce parti qui veulent
continuer à voter pour la droite
et bien non que faire deux sens commun
et des idées de sens commun quand ils ne
sont pas la colonne vertébrale des
républicains accessoirement ils sont
plus conservateurs que réactionnaire
sans doute dans l'heureux que dans la
réalité ça veut dire quoi sens comme un
bon sens bah oui sens commun ça veut
dire le bon sens que si c'est appeler le
bon sens on aurait peut-être mieux
compris alors quand on joue pour nous ce
qu'on passe à mes autres son sujet vous
sans doute ne connaissiez vous pas
christophe arena à moins d'être un
spécialiste de la vie politique
c'est un député la république en marche
de moselle il est sous les feux des
projecteurs depuis ce week-end
depuis que une ancienne collaboratrice
l'a accusé de harcèlement sexuel
vous savez dans cette campagne de 2,2 à
plat comme vous voulez de 2,2 de
dénonciation le terme n'est pas
forcément désobligeants dans la bouche
de harcèlement divers et très savard est
dit mais non c'est pas vrai du tout il
c'est parole contre parole c'est la
présomption d'innocence contre des
accusations très très précises jeu pour
vous écouter deux points de vue sur
cette affaire celui de richard ferrand
c'est le patron du groupe la république
en marche l'assemblée nationale et celui
de marlène schiappa la désormais célèbre
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
écoutez aujourd'hui ce que je sais c'est
que il y à des accusations graves
portées contre monsieur arrêtez ce que
je sais aussi c'est qu'il a lui déposé
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse
nous sommes dans un pays où le même
roule on aime rappeler qu'il ya
présomption d'innocence
donc il faut prendre cela en compte
ce qui est essentiel c'est ce qui est
essentiel je pense tant pour la personne
qui porte les accusations que nous avons
entendu que pour la personne qui nie ces
accusations
il faut que la lumière soit faite et
vite quand on exerce des responsabilités
politiques le droit commun s'applique et
doit s'appliquer c'est à dire qu'il ne
doit pas y avoir de protection
particulière pour les députés à cet
égard il y a dans notre droit pour lui
comme pour tout comme pour tariq ramadan
comme pour les autres noms présomption
d'innocence jusqu'à la condamnation et
nous verrons de la condamnation mais
bien évidemment s'il était mise en
examen ou condamner je pense que sa
place ne pourrait plus être à
l'assemblée nationale b à lyon on sent
une espèce de gènes hla parce que d'un
côté il ya des accusations qui sont qui
sont fortes et de l'autre côté il ya cet
homme qui nie et on se dit mais ce qu'on
est allé trop loin dans ce mouvement de
deux de dénonciation bon c'est vrai que
je sais très bien que la parole se
délivre en même temps c'est vrai qu'on
évitera sans doute pas un moment donné
dans ce cas là dans un autre un système
de vengeance etc ou de délation on peut
pas éviter dans ce type de deux
campagnes des gens qui vont en profiter
pour se venger de quelque chose pour ce
donc c'est presse et c'est très délicat
mais le moi je suis quand même
atterrée par ce que j'entends tous les
jours
et je crois que ces personnes là doivent
tête doivent être sanctionnés mais moi
ce qui me gêne un peu c'est un peu ce
que disait natacha polony chez vous
samedi dernier dire continuer à faire la
différence
une forme de virilité de bienséance de
courtoisie de la part d'un homme est ce
qu'on appelle le harcèlement sexuel ça
n'a rien à voir parce que si on arrive à
une société où comme aux états unis moi
j'ai travaillé aux états unis où quand
vous montez dans l'ascenseur avec une
femme vous regardez que les bouton de
l'ascenseur et des étages pour pas être
accusé de l'avoir harcelé et ensuite
vous ne recevez pas une femme dans un
bureau sans avoir la porte grande
ouverte
on va vers une société et qui à mon avis
n'est pas tellement vivable non c'est
sûr que s'ils voulaient faut se méfier
du tribunal médiatique quand même moi
c'est quelque chose qui m'effraie on a
toujours l'impression de découvrir l'eau
chaude alors que le sujet dont on parle
qui est un sujet grave on l'a déjà
évoqué quand il ya une affaire dominique
strauss kahn ou moi personnellement je
me suis employé justement à dire qu' il
fallait quand même faire la distinction
entre un homme qui est volontiers
dragueur ce que passait pour être
dominique strauss kahn est quelqu'un qui
agresse une femme c'est quand même
complètement différent
c'est un sujet qui a été aussi mis sur
la table quand il affaire denis baupin
qui s'est terminée entre parenthèses
d'ailleurs par un non lieu je passe
détaillé denis baupin pardon c'est quand
même à chaque fois on a l'impression
qu'on découvre on sait qu'on est dans
une société où quand même je pense que
le règlement de ce genre de 2,2 de
sujets qu'il faut c'est des sujets
extrêmement douloureux eh bien ça
progresse quand même je j'imagine qu'il
ya 30 40 ans il se passe exactement les
mêmes choses des choses aussi horribles
aussi affreuse et que les femmes
répudiées répudier en parler on en
parlait très peu
c'était des sujets qui n'étaient pas du
tout mis sur la place publique et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui
et bien ce qu'il faut c'est que les
forces de l'ordre qui sont appelés à
prendre les plaintes à recueillir les
plaintes et puis la magistrature et bien
doit être un peu plus familiarisés à
c'est à ces problèmes là voilà
simplement moi je suis contre le
tribunal médiatique et je pense que
quand il ya quelque chose comme ça il
faut que ça se passe
sûr dans la justice la justice pénale en
jus face une pièce au dossier
si vous voulez réagir vous le ferai avec
une intervention de christine boutin qui
a pris sa retraite politique ce week-end
et qui a dit des choses assez assez
forte on va dire les faits reprochés par
ces femmes
c'était en général dans ce dont
notamment danse dans ce que la campagne
de libération de la parole sur twitter
ne sont rien d'autre qu'une pincée de
machisme hérité de la grivoiserie qui
fait partie de l'identité française
c'est à dire ça n'est pas si grave
houdaille d'habiter dans cette dernière
en fait déclaration à se perdre en
rapport avec l annoncer la mort de
jacques chirac sur twitter il ya
quelques mois je dis pas ça pour être
légitime et c'est un point de vue mais
en tout cas lorsqu'on voit le nombre de
tweets sur ce sujet il y en a plus de de
plus de 400 milles il ya des gars d'à
côté une vraie libération de la parole
de l'autre pour rebondir sur ce que ea
vient de dire il ya aussi un sentiment
d'impasse de la part des fans puisque a
eu des chiffres assez éloquent 94 % des
plaintes suite à des faits de
harcèlement sexuel ne sont sont déclarés
sans suite a tant que les faits ne sont
pas calculés dit il est difficile de
dire hey caractériser l'infraction
c'est vrai que du point de vue de la
sphère politique on en a parlé il ya une
affaire il ya eu un moment un début de
libération de la parole au moins deux
affaires dominique strauss kahn il ya eu
en 2015 le l'appel bas les pattes d'une
quarantaine de journalistes politiques
femme qui avait fait du bruit mais il ya
aussi le sentiment que qu'on ne va pas
au bout des choses et que libé enfin les
fans ne peuvent que libérer leur parole
dans un cadre aussi où tous les faits un
antérieurs à 2002 ont été prescrits
puisque la loi a été abrogée en mai 2012
et a été refaite sur le harcèlement en
juillet ou en août 2012 on tient aussi
un problème je dirais d'un parce que
ressentent beaucoup de femmes alors on a
beaucoup on a parlé au départ de ces
affaires de harcèlement à la suite d d d
accusations portées contre 1 un
producteur américain donc c'était le
monde du cinéma ça se focalisent plutôt
ces derniers jours sur le monde
politique je version une nouvelle pièce
au dossier écouter ce que dit marine ton
d'heuliez s'est tue deux élus
d'opposition au conseil municipal
d'hénin beaumont depuis 2014 est une
élue europe écologie les verts elle
avait travaillé comme collaboratrice
parlementaire d'une député europe
ecologie les verts et elle était hier
dans l'émission 19 heures le dimanche
tous les jours vous avez les remarques
sur vos tenues vestimentaires sur le
maquillage que vous portez sur le fait
que vous êtes bien sympathique que
vraiment votre intervention
ah bah je vais aujourd'hui je vais la
lire je parle pas là de ce que moi j'ai
vécu parce qu'en plus je travaille pour
des femmes donc c'est réglé mais je vais
la lire avec encore plus d'engouement
parce que maintenant je sais que cette
fois qu'il a écrits de ça donne beaucoup
d'énergie méritez vous ne deviez pas
votre collaboratrice premièrement et
deuxièmement il y a un rapport
hiérarchique qui fait que c'est encore
plus grave
et troisièmement c'est que c'est répéter
tout le temps ses insistances est lourd
et et jamais une femme ne va faire ça
avec son collaborateur hommes alexandre
avec pio que quand on est dans une
relation professionnelle encore plus si
elle y arracher qu on ne drague plus
c'est ce que dit cette femme vous êtes
d'accord
s'il ya une pression par rapport à un
avancement des choses comme ça mais
faire un compliment à sa collègue de
travail je pense que ça devrait toujours
autorisés faye a rien là de
répréhensible par la loi est ce qu'il me
gêne un peu dans le délai at-on auquel
on assiste et qu'effectivement on
alléger la tâche qu'on a des choses
comme il m'a envoyé un texto à 2 heures
du matin où il m'a fait tel ou tel
compliment et on amalgame ça avec dédé
des faits de viol je pense qu'il faut
quand même raison garder et voir que
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose et
qu'il faudrait pas non plus prendre la
place des vrais victimes de l'histoire
puisque les mêmes aujourd'hui qui sont
les plus hystériques sur ce sujet
expliquait par exemple dans le quartier
de la chapelle pajol où les femmes ne
pouvaient plus passer il avait mardi
soir dans le jama ralentissement ne
pouvait plus passer dans dans ce
quartier là parce que effectivement il y
avait des comportements d'hommes
intimidant violeau ces mêmes femmes qui
sont là hystérique expliqué qu'il
fallait agrandir les trottoirs ou que
c'était un problème
de luminosité des rues donc il faut être
cohérent et je trouve qu'ils se battent
plus courageux de dénoncer par exemple
la situation des femmes dans certaines
cités les pour nantes et c'est une
espèce de laxisme des magistrats qui
relâchent facilement les gens qui sont
condamnés pour viol etc etc donc
donc voila moi je joue je commence à
trouver tout cela un peu excessif et
dangereux
surtout que quand même que je sache
jusqu'à aujourd'hui une majorité de
mariages se font entre
collaborateur d'une même entreprise
souvent se rend compte sur son lieu de
travail donc si on n'a plus le droit de
parler à une femme ou un homme sur son
lieu de travail il va y avoir un certain
nombre de mariages en moi et là comme la
loi le projet de loi de madame schiappa
epa est difficile à mettre en
application puisqu'il s'agirait de
verbaliser tout comportement à caractère
à soleure je dirais dans la rue ce qui
sera très difficile à prouver parce que
sauf est pris en flagrant délit je vois
pas très bien comment cette législation
pour entrer en application
1 un commentaire une précision de l'oea
qui nous dit le harcèlement sexuel c'est
l'action répéter un ne vous trompez pas
de combat donc on est d'accord que c'est
pas un c'est pas un compliment ou
isolées voire voire même une avance
parce que parce que à ce qu' a priori
oui c'est ça la difficulté de de cette
définition
je vous propose pour terminer de parler
de foot et là je m'accroche à mes notes
il y avait ce week end un match entre le
paris saint germain et marseille ça
s'est terminé sur une égalité 2-2 mais
ça a été assez chaud neymar de la star
du psg un footballeur brésilien qui a
signé pour 222 millions d'euros
c'est un record mondial pour le psg a
été expulsé pour deux cartons jaunes
consécutifs
il se plaignait d'avoir été maltraité
par des joueurs d'en face
écoutez passé
et qu'ils continuent
briscoe cabg landau tomana cette façon
qu'on ne sait pas encore qui talonne
pour le times and joe parade est encore
à l'abri zoé office tout cas la miche
qoussaya pas laissés au repos comme à ce
que je radote
alors on n'est pas dans une émission de
football donc moi je voudrais c'est
qu'on généralise un petit peu le propos
on a vu des comportements on se dit mais
c'est ça le football d'aujourd'hui alors
commençons par le comportement des
joueurs est ce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
de plus en plus de gestes violents
brutaux sur le terrain pour essayer de
gêner l'autre
écoutez moi je suis le football depuis
fort longtemps
on peut dire que le football des années
depuis les années 80 et plus viril que
par le passé et c'est je pars faire
l'histoire du football mais c'est depuis
le sauna appelé le football total vous
voyez c'est le football initiée par les
néerlandais johan cruijff qui était un
football d'engagement physique très fort
et c'est vrai que le physique compte
beaucoup
et en plus vous avez des gabarits
aujourd'hui mais ça c'est du c'est une
évolution de la société on doit bien les
gens sont plus grands plus grand plus
fort plus plus plus musclée et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une grande virilité
le problème avec neymar si on prend
quelques et un mauvais joueur n'est
maintenant c'est pas ça c'est que les
grands joueurs je dis absolument les
grands joueurs sont évidemment la cible
de coups irrégulier beaucoup plus que
l'autre d'autres joueurs ce qu'ils sont
difficiles à saisir
neymar est un très grand joueur on peut
pas le nier un très bon technicien et
parfois pour l'arrêter dans ses
adversaires commettront des fautes et
des fautes qui sont inacceptables c'est
vrai mais il n'a pas eu plus dans ce
match là car les ont tués par match
décousu alors pas spécialement non mais
ce que vient de dire y verrait bien
réelle c'est à dire que l'évolution du
football comme ceux du rugby va vers une
virilité
beaucoup plus accentuée que par le passé
avec des physiques si vous regardez par
exemple les joueurs de l'équipe de
france de rugby des années 70 avec jean
gachassin qui fait un mètre cinquante
d'eux je sais pas comment il pourrait
aujourd'hui jouer au rugby et au
football raymond kopa qui faisait lui
aussi un maître 62s qu'il pourrait
continuer à jouer un beau football
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on a vu hier soir
moi je fais un peu plus un peu plus dur
que clive c'est que voilà hier soir il
s'est passé ce qui se passe aujourd hui
en football c'est l'argent la violence
mois pour moi hier soir c'est l'exemple
même c'est la violence dire avant le
stade il ya des manifestations pendant
le match les pour des raisons
inexpliquées mais de violence à l'égard
de quelqu'un qui a coûté très cher à
paris on lui envoie des canettes de soda
ou des chiffons des cailloux des jus
d'orange
j'ai vu de carla dont il ya une violence
ces gens qui sont dans la tribune et qui
font ça n'a rien à voir avec le football
et aujourd'hui vous avez de plus en plus
dans dans le dans le football
ce type de comportement c'est à dire que
le supporters est devenu aujourd'hui
quelqu'un c'est un cetain souvent un
voyou c'est que c'est parfois un
délinquant il vient pas là pour regarder
d'ailleurs vous verrez vous verrez
souvent que les supporters pendant les
matches il tourne le dos au match cela
dit pour eux daniel a raison il faut
déplorer la violence dans les stades
mais c'est pas irréversible si vous
prenez le paris saint-germain puisqu'il
est question du paris saint germain
et c'est vrai que le paris saint germain
et l'olympique de marseille ont deux
clubs de supporters parfois un tueur un
peu turbulents mais par exemple au paris
saint-germain au parc des princes où il
y avait une violence mais qui était une
violence haineuse pour le coup nazis ont
d'ailleurs
et bien une politique ferme on doit
rendre hommage à aux dirigeants du paris
saint germain est bien a permis de
nettoyer si vous me permettez
complètement le public du paris saint
germain
aujourd'hui vous ne voyez plus cette
violence qui existaient y compris dans
les dents les mots qu'ils étaient
proférées dans le stade donc c'est
possible de lutter contre ça et ça
marche au paris saint germain ça a été
ça a été prouvé
donc faut pas désespérer je passe la
parole à frédéric dabi après vous à part
donner le point de vue du goût qui nous
dit neymar est un super joueur mais
aujourd'hui il faut que les footballeurs
retrouve du respect et de l'humidité
vous ne verrez jamais un rugbyman
critiqué un arbitre mais ça va commencer
ça on a vu ça commence aussi l'intérêt
qu'il ya une attente d'exemplarité vis à
vis des joueurs italie le joueur qui ont
coûté cher
on avait fait une enquête et quelques
années il ya deux trois ans sur zlatan
ibrahimovic ont avec son l'image qu'il
avait auprès des français et auprès des
fans de foot c'était un petit peu
dégradées suite aussi à des cartons
rouges suite à un moment où il avait il
avait parlé de championnat de merde si
je ne me trompe pas c'est vrai qu'il ya
une attente des vents parité forte
d'autant plus que le transfert et le
coût du transfert de neymar a bien
marqué les français n'y a pas eu un
rejet viscéral mais ça enracine le
football dans le monde de l'argent c'est
vrai aussi que les grands joueurs se
font matraquer
rappelez-vous daniel ne vous en souvenez
très bien coupe du monde 82 maradona
dans un match contre l'italie ce le fait
vraiment mais absolument marcher dessus
pendant quasiment tout le match ils
répliquent et le carton rouge c'est lui
qui le prend c'est un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé hier alexandre devez donc
vous brûlez d'envié pour ma part
spécialement mais alors pas pour le
match d'hier ni pour 1 m eur qui à mon
avis à un joueur plutôt correct et là on
peut le comprendre on se souvient qu'il
a été blessé quand même très durement
durant la coupe du monde au brésil est
fayez être paralysé donc on peut
comprendre son agacement et c'est
quelqu'un qui est plutôt correct sur le
terrain mais on va pas qu'ils jouent
dans l'équipe nationale du brésil
évidemment doctrinale de capitaine
mais on voit effectivement de manière
plus générale et dans l'est dans les
tribunes et aussi sur le terrain
certains joueurs se comportait un peu
que vous faut le dire comme des
racailles qui crachent sur leurs
collègues qui donne des coups de boule
d'ailleurs on avait trouvé ça presque
formidable à l'époque c'était là une
eddine zidane donc le football n'échappe
pas aux maux de la société et sont
peut-être encore aggravée puisque le
football moderne c'est aussi la société
de consommation dans toute sa puissance
il ya aussi un phénomène nouveau c'est
que on n'a pas souligner c'est qu'il ya
des arbitres aujourd'hui qui aime bien
se faire remarquer et qui sont prêt à
gâcher des matches pour faire preuve
d'autorité et se faire connaître
ça c'est quelque chose qui est nouveau
aussi cela dit que c'était normal qu'il
se fasse expulser hier parce que quand
bien même il se fait agresser parce
qu'il se fait agresser par le moelleux
l'ancien monégasque néo-marseillais
ocampo ce mes
il a il a quand même un geste qui est du
même ordre même s'il n'ya pas le coup de
boule est du même ordre que celui de
zidane mais ça se fait pas sur un
terrain de football donc c'est normal
qu'ils soient expulsés
je pense pas que ce soit une affaire
d'état il sera privé de match
probablement la prochaine fois parce que
quand vous vous êtes expulsés d'un
terrain vous n'avez pas le droit de
jouer la fois suivante
bon c'est la vie du football je dirais
un mais sincèrement pour un match comme
celui d'hier qui est toujours très
attendu face à ces psg parce que c'est
psg om les deux plus grandes villes de
france et puis que c'est le sud contrôle
nord enfin il ya tous les symboles c'est
pas un match violent hier sur le terrain
j'entends c'est beaucoup plus violent
effectivement dans les tribunes à tel
point que les supporters parisiens on
était interdit de faire le déplacement
pour aller supporter leur équipe ce qui
est tout à fait ce qui est normal compte
tenu de la violence qui pourrait
s'exprimer mais on sait détestable ce
genre de comportement donc il faut le
rappeler que le match d'hier était un
match correct
en dehors de sa famille est ce que les
français sont sensibles à ce ce genre de
dérives même si c'était pas à
caractériser hier ou bien est-ce que
c'est comme pour le vélo on ce qui se
passe des trucs qu'on aime pas beaucoup
mais tant pis ça reste un sport très
populaire
moi ça reste un sport extrêmement en
fête populaire on a toujours il ya eu
d'ailleurs un vrai basculement c'est une
question que l'ifop ce depuis très
longtemps sur le club de football
préféré pendant très longtemps ça a été
saint-etienne puis ça a été
marseille est depuis quelques années
c'est devenu paris alors pendant très
longtemps c'était un clapotis suscité
des réactions extrêmement contrastées
oui et non c'est vrai que l'on il ya eu
un très bon ressenti de l'opinion de
l'euro 2016 et on a très vite fait
oublier qu'il ya eu à marseille lors du
match russie angleterre en marge de ce
match
des violences sur la canebière et sur le
vieux-port absolument inacceptable
actions de vector le mot de la fin là
dessus non il ya peut-être une pour la
dernière question il ya une chose à dire
c'est
à l'époque de saint-etienne les joueurs
ressembler peut-être plus à l'ouvrier
qui allaient qui allait les voir
aujourd'hui on a quand même des salaires
déments et des gens qui sont déconnectés
du reste de la réalité telle et des fils
de mineur polonais qui devenait joueur
de football non moi je pense que les
gens l'acceptent aujourd'hui je vais
faire quelque chose de votre tête vous
dire quelque chose qui va nous sembler
bizarre mais à partir du moment où on
passe de citoyens consommateurs on
accepte beaucoup plus ce type de console
de comportement il faut être plus vous
avez des choses intelligentes
merci à tous les quatre et à demain pour
un prochain point de vue bonsoir
[Musique]